[Musique]
quand on pense à l'irrigation des champs
on pense souvent aux productions
maraîchères aux petits fruits aux
légumes mais avec les sécheresses que
l'on vient à répétition de plus en plus
de culture manque d'eau lité et des
producteurs qui n'aurait jamais pensé
arroser leurs chants songe désormais à
les irriguer
[Musique]
mais toi une période dans l'été où ce
choeur on manque beaucoup d'eau
c'est dispo reggae je vous demande
hockey qui travaillent jour et nuit
quand c'est sec fait longtemps qu'on
pense assure on se pose toujours la
question si on mettra de l'eau qu'est ce
que ça donnerait
[Musique]
la production laitière c'est avant tout
un bon troupeau mais c'est aussi des
tonnes et des tonnes de nourriture
notamment des plantes fourragères
cultivés à la ferme
une vache normal 26 à 27 kg de matière
sèche par jour chez jean claude poyot le
foin ensilage le maïs d'ensilage et le
foin sec représentent l'essentiel de
l'alimentation de ces bêtes autant dans
nos 3 6e on a mis un peu plus que mille
tonnes d'ensilage de maïs en stock
puis on a environ 500 tonnes hausse
l'âge de foin puis on pense aux dans
notre hiver mais depuis quelques années
le producteur a de plus en plus de
difficultés à nourrir ses 110 vaches en
lactation le printemps dernier il s'est
presque rendu au bout de ses réserves
avant la fin de l'hiver arrivé à
première coupe
il ne restait de deux grosses bagues
comme sow
[Musique]
c'est que les étés sont chauds et les
épisodes de sécheresse de plus en plus
fréquents les rendements en fourrage en
souffre beaucoup
à l'été 2010 8 une pénurie de foin a
d'ailleurs frappé plusieurs régions du
québec
obligeant des éleveurs à
s'approvisionner à l'extérieur à des cui
exorbitants la crise aura coûté 60
millions de dollars en indemnisations
ce n'est guère mieux cette année je
presse du foie pour dos aux toqués puis
ccg j'ai vu des rendements absolument
désolés cette année là qui en termes de
sécheresse lla d'un pratiquement rien
d'achat promène pourriez le chercheur
karl boivin a entrepris cette année un
projet pilote d'irrigation des plantes
fourragères sur les terres de jean
claude pouliot
on le voit le mur et si c'est dingue
sont vos pas le sol alors que la portion
dont erik guay on voit seuls ces arbres
à un pied de route très fleurie avocat
le subit un stress le manque d'eau
l'irrigation des champs de foin est une
pratique quasi inexistante au québec
elle est pourtant utilisé ailleurs
canadiens surtout ces dernières années
ont les pleins de foi gens sont beaucoup
plus démunis comme britannique aussi aux
états unis simon et des conditions
incertaines les gens qui on lit des
conditions à l'aide également ou s'ils
répondent d'irrigation meilleur est
probablement un pote de planfoy joueur
avec son projet de recherches carles
boivin espère trouver réponse à
plusieurs questions parce que c'est
rentable de faire ce que c'est pertinent
c'est quoi les défis ça prend combien
d'eau de la luzerne dans des conditions
de production québec
l'île d'orléans est le laboratoire idéal
les producteurs agricoles de l'île
connaissent de sérieux problèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau les réserves
souterraines sont limitées et ils ne
peuvent pas puisée dans la nappe
phréatique
jean claude poyot lui pompe son eau dans
trois étangs de surface qui capte l'eau
de la fonte des neiges et les
précipitations est au dessus de 400 lac
si vous prenez une photo aérienne allait
leur revient il ya énormément de l'acdic
servent à l'irrigation pour le projet
pilote
le chercheur a choisi quatre parcelles
expérimentales et reggae et quatre
parcelles témoins il a caractérisé le
sol puis installer des sondes qui
permettent de savoir à quel moment les
plantes subissent un stress hydrique
donc à chaque fois qu'on a gagné la
consigne de déclenchement qu'on avait
déterminé en fonction de sol qu'on avait
ici ont déclenché le l'irrigation pour
appliquer 20 minimum avant la première
coupe fait autour de la saint jean
baptiste
la pluie a été suffisante pour répondre
aux besoins des plantes fourragères
en juillet le temps chaud et sec s'est
installé il a fallu irriguer les
parcelles expérimentales à deux reprises
avant la deuxième coupe les rendements
et ont été jusqu'à 25 % plus élevé que
dans les parcelles témoins et pour se
rendre à la troisième coupe faim ou la
consigne d'irrigation s'est déclenché
quatre fois
résultats les rendements ont explosé 70
% plus élevé jean claude poyot a fait
analyser les fourrages des parcelles et
lido il est satisfait de la qualité
c'est un petit peu plus fibreuse que le
reste a dit que ce qui est pauvre
irriguer un petit peu plus fibreux avec
un peu moins de protéines mais la manne
mince et c'est magnifique
[Musique]
si les résultats sont en balance
l'approvisionnement en eau lui demeure
problématique pour une irrigation à
grande échelle
même si on n'arrose pas souvent
c'est 100 m que alao que ça promettent
un pouce d'eau et
si on parle de 180 da ou présentement
que j'ai ce après dix-huit mille mètres
que savoir la colombie
une partie de la solution se trouve
peut-être dans cette immense réserve
d'eau naturelle qui borde l'île
d'orléans en capable de transporter des
millions de baril pétrole sur détroit
4000 km j'imagine qu'on doit être
capable de pomper de l'eau puis la
montée sur deux trop tu la main mais
plusieurs obstacles se dressent avant
d'en arriver là à la fois sur le plan
sanitaire environnementale et de
l'acceptabilité sociale et il faudra
évidemment déterminer si l'irrigation
peut être rentable à long terme est ce
qu'on doit investir 200 milliards et ce
thème d'irrigation en sachant qu'on va
avoir régulièrement rendement à toutes
les années où acheter une table de 400
milles de marty peut-être de fourrage
paraît qu'on est quand même content de
son projet de recherche n'en est encore
qu'à ses débuts mais pour qu'un robot à
20 l'irrigation du foin s'annoncent
prometteuses dans une culture comme les
que sauf de plantes fourragères maniry
gassion je vois avant tout comme un
l'assurance récolte
[Musique]